is really in the United States are about
to celebrate a historic transition the
US Embassy in Israel officially moves
from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem this morning
Palestinians angry about the move are
holding new protests on the Gaza Israel
border today Israeli troops reportedly
killed at least 12 protesters
Palestinians have been demonstrating for
weeks saying the u.s. is no longer a
partner in the peace process for
president Trump this is a proud moment
in the fulfillment of a promise is
daughter Ivanka and her husband White
House senior advisor Jared Kushner will
represent him at this morning's ceremony
Seth Doane is at the new Embassy site in
Jerusalem with the latest on this story
Seth good morning good morning it is a
celebratory atmosphere here people are
starting to take their seats for this
event which is being staged just in
front of the new US embassy building
here in Jerusalem representatives from
86 different countries were invited less
than half sent their people underlining
just how controversial this embassy move
is there was some fine-tuning this
morning as workers prepared for the 800
guests expected at today's embassy
opening among the US delegation are
Ivanka Trump and husband Jared Kushner
who's in charge of developing the Trump
administration's Middle East peace
process the Palestinians say moving the
embassy sets the peace process back it
stalls it well there's nothing to stall
at the moment if Dan Shapiro was a US
ambassador to Israel under President
Obama if you were still the ambassador
if you had that secure line to president
Donald Trump what would you say to him
I'd say if we're moving our embassy to
Jerusalem which is a perfectly
legitimate and reasonable thing to do
let's describe it in the full context of
the two-state solution that we envision
Shapiro thinks the u.s. embassy move
should ultimately be paired with the
promise of a US Embassy to a future
Palestinian state to be built in East
Jerusalem
that's something the Trump
administration has not articulated well
the peace process is in trouble
nabil shot is a longtime Palestinian
peace negotiator who argues that by the
u.s. moving its embassy to Jerusalem it
is unilaterally sided with Israel on the
status of a city also claimed by
Palestinian
from our point of view what mr. Trump
has done is destroyed the role of the
United States as an honest broker but
many Israelis are applauding president
Trump's mood and they filled Jerusalem
streets celebrating the decisive Israeli
war victory of more than 50 years ago
it's an annual celebration but this year
they told us it meant more with the u.s.
embassy mood earlier today we spoke with
senators Lindsey Graham and Ted Cruz who
underlined that in 1995 a bipartisan
Congress agreed to voted to move the
u.s. embassy here every single u.s.
president after that issued a waiver due
to security concerns Nora
all right sat down in Jerusalem thank
you